the science progress
via paradigm shifts and uh revolutions
as philosopher thomas kuhn said or does
it progress gradually what do you think
well i got into this field because i was
tom coons research assistant 50 years
ago 52 years ago
he pulled me into it out of physics
instead
so i know his work pretty well and in
the years when i was at mit running an
institute he was then in the philosophy
department used to come over all the
time
to the talks we held and so on
so what would i say about that he of
course developed his ideas a lot over
the years yes the thing that he's famous
for the
uh structure of scientific revolutions
came out in 62
and um
as you just said it offered
an outline for what he called a
paradigmatic structure namely the notion
that
you have to look at what scientists do
is forming a community
of investigators
and that they're trying to solve various
puzzles as he would put it that crop up
figuring out how this works how that
works and so on and of course they don't
do it out of the blue they do it within
a certain framework the framework can be
pretty vague he called it a paradigm
and his notion was that eventually they
run into troubles or what he called
anomalies that kind of cracks things
somebody new comes along
with a different way of doing it etc do
i think things work that way no not
really
tom and i used to have lengthy
discussions about that over the years
i do think there is a common structure
that formulates both theoretical and
experimental practices
and historians nowadays of science like
to refer to scientific work as what
scientists practice it's uh almost
craftsmen like
they can usually adapt in various ways
and i can give you all kinds of examples
of that i
once wrote a book on the origins of wave
theory of light and that is one of the
paradigmatic examples that tom used only
it didn't work that way
exactly because he thought that what
happened was that the
wave theory ran into trouble with a
certain phenomenon which it couldn't
crack
well it turned out that in fact
historically that phenomenon was
actually um
not relevant
later on to the wave theory and when the
wave theory came in
the alternative to it which had
prevailed which was newton's views of
light as particles
that it seemed couldn't explain what the
wave theory could explain again not true
not true
and much more complex than that the wave
theory
offered the opportunity to deploy
novel experimental and mathematical
structures which gave younger
scientists mathematicians and others the
opportunity
to
effect
manufacture make
new sorts of devices
it's not that the alternative couldn't
sort of explain these things but it
never was able to generate them
de novo as novelties in other words if
you think of it as something scientists
want to
progress in the sense of finding new
stuff to solve
then i think what often happens is is
that it's not so much that the
prevailing view can't crack something as
that it doesn't give you the opportunity
to do new stuff
when you say new stuff are we referring
to experimental science here or new
stuff in the space of uh new theories
could be both it could be both actually
so how does that can maybe elaborate a
little bit on the story of the wave
sure
the prevailing view of light
at least in france where the wave theory
really first took off although it had
been introduced in england by thomas
young the prevailing theory dates back
to newton that light is a stream of
particles and that refraction and
reflection involve sort of repulsive and
attractive forces
that deflect and bend the paths of these
particles
newton was not able successfully to deal
with the phenomenon of
what happens when light goes past a
knife's edge or a sharp edge what we now
call diffraction
he had
he cooked up something about it that no
mathematical structure could be applied
thomas young first but really this guy
named augustan fernell in france
deployed
in fresnel's case rather advanced
calculus forms
of mathematics which enabled
computations to be done
and observations to be melded with these
computations in a way that you could not
do or see how to do with newton did that
mean that the newtonian explanation of
what goes on in diffraction fails
not really you can you can actually
make it work but you can't generate
anything new out of it whereas
using the mathematics of wave optics in
respect to a particular phenomenon
called polarization
which ironically was discovered by
partisans of newton's way of doing
things
you were able to generate devices
which reflect light in crystals do
various things
that the newtonian way
could accommodate only after the fact
they couldn't generate it from the
beginning and so if you want to be
uh somebody who is working a novel vein
which increasingly becomes the case with
uh
people who become what we now call
physicists in the 1820s 30s and 40s in
particular then that's the direction
you're going to go but there were
holdouts until the 1850s
i want to try to elaborate on the nature
of the disagreement you have with thomas
kuhn so do you still believe in paradigm
shifts do you still see that there is
ideas that really have a
transformational effect on science
you just the nature of the disagreement
has to do with how those
paradigm shifts come to be
how they come to be and how they change
i certainly think they exist
how strong they may be at any given time
is maybe not quite as powerful as tom
thought in general
although towards the end of his life he
was beginning to develop
different
modifications of his original way of
thinking
but i don't think that the changes
happen quite so
neatly if you will in reaction to
novel experimental observations
making much more complex than that
you